Welcome to 3ABN Today Bible Q&A. My name
is J. D Quinn. It's my pleasure to be
the host of this great program.
What the numbers tell us that this is
one of your favorite programs. People
watch Bible Q&A and they love it because
of the people that and the research that
y'all do. And so, normally we ask, "What
do you like about the program?" But
we're going to do this a little bit
differently. James James Rafferty. He's
sitting in chair number one in
Vanderbolts in uh seat number two.
Shelley Quinn in uh seat number three.
Seat number three. James, 20 or less.
What do you like about uh 3ABN Bible
Q&A?
>> I love 3ABN Bible Q&A because it gives
us an opportunity to connect with our
viewers where they have questions. You
know, it's one thing to preach a sermon.
You got a title, you got a subject,
you're preaching away, but it's another
thing to actually meet the needs, the
felt needs of people who are studying
the Bible and coming across questions
they need help answering.
>> Wow, it's great answer.
>> Ian, what do you like about Bible Q&A?
>> All right, 20 words or less.
>> 20 words or less.
uh you know it's just a you know to I
guess um continue what James was saying
it's just it's an opportunity to really
to connect but what I enjoy about it is
it challenges me
>> you know sometimes I will intentionally
choose things that I don't know how to
answer and I want to research for myself
so that if I'm ever asked that question
again I know how to respond to it so
it's it really helps me as well as you
know helping the viewers as well.
>> Well we've certainly seen you grow a
lot.
>> Well praise God.
>> Amen. Praise Shelley Quinn.
>> And I would ditto what James said and
Ian said. I think what I also like about
it is that we learn from each other.
>> You know your questions. Sometimes we
get the most interesting questions and
it's like I've never even thought about
that. So we love it.
>> We love your questions. You're the one
to send the questions into us. Let me
the three ways that we get your
questions. number one. If you want to
text them in, that's 6182283975.
You'll see it at the bottom of the
monitor. If you want to email it, it's
bible qa3abn.tv.
And if you'd like to use Instagram,
3ABN_official.
We look forward to getting your
questions.
Let's start off with prayer. Love to
start everything off with prayer.
Father, we come to you in the name of
Jesus. And we want to thank you, Lord,
for this opportunity to be able to get
into your word, Father. So, we just ask
to be emptied of self, filled with you,
Lord, so that as we go forward that
we'll bring glory to you and you only.
We love you and we thank you in the name
of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> James, we're going to start with you. Go
from James to Ian to Shellyley and back
and forth and back and forth.
What is the meaning of the tale referred
to in Revelation 12:4? And this is from
Tony and Canada.
Well, Tony, thank you for your question.
This text itself actually answers itself
in its context. So, let's just look at
Revelation 12:es 3 and 4. We'll read in
its context and we'll get some
understanding from it. And there
appeared another wonder in heaven. And
behold, a great red dragon having seven
heads and 10 horns, and the seven crowns
upon his heads. And his tail drew the
third part of the stars of heaven, and
he cast them to the earth. And the
dragon stood before the woman which was
ready to be delivered or to devour her
child as soon as it was born. So Lucifer
here is going to be identified as this
dragon, and we'll see that in some
verses we'll read here in a second. How
did he cast the third part of the stars
that is heavenly angels to this earth?
Well, it was by his deceptions about
God. You know, Revelation is a book that
borrows its symbolism from the entire
Bible. So, when we want to understand
what these symbols mean, we search the
scriptures. And we can do this by
looking up the word tale and in the
Strong's concordance in a Strongs app or
a hard copy book. And uh let me just put
a plug in here for our 3ABN school of
disciplehip Ian where we can learn how
to study the Bible and discover the
meaning of the Greek and Hebrew words.
Just go to 3ABNs.com
and learn how you can be part of the
next oneweek session that we have in
October. Anyway, we look up the word
tale. We go to the Old Testament. We
start looking up verses and we come
across this verse in Isaiah 9 and verse1
15. It says the ancient and the
honorable, he is the head and the
prophet that teaches lies, he is the
tail.
>> So the idea of the devil deceiving the
heavenly angels is established here in
Isaiah 9:15. He did it through his lies.
He did it through his deception. Now
this idea is further elaborated on later
in Revelation 12. Let's just look at
Revelation 12 7-9. Says there was war in
heaven. Michael and his angels fought
against the dragon and the dragon and
fought and his angels and prevailed not.
Neither was their place found in anymore
in heaven. The great dragon was cast
out. That old serpent called the devil
and Satan which deceived the whole
world. He was cast into the earth and
his angels were cast out with him. This
is actually where everything that we've
talked about is laid out clearly. Right?
You've got the devil which is the
dragon. He's identified as the devil.
He's identified as Satan, as the old
serpent, and his angels. So there you
have the stars identified as the angels.
And then you have, of course, his
deception. He deceives the whole world.
So he's cast out into the earth. The
third part of the angels cast out into
the earth with him. And why is how is he
how is it that he did he deceived them?
By his lies. Right? Lucifer deceived
heavenly angels. We know he deceived
Adam and Eve or at least Eve in the
Garden of Eden. And Adam, of course,
went along with that. And then in
according to Revelation 12:7-9, he
deceives the whole world. So the word
there, tale, is a symbol that is used in
the book of Revelation to describe
Satan's lies. How he deceived the
unfallen angels, one-third of them, and
then came to this earth, deceived Eve,
mankind, and then goes out to deceive
the whole world. Deception is the key
point here that is made in these verses.
I hope that's helpful for you, Tony, in
seeking to understand the meaning of the
word tale.
>> That's a great job on that. Very good.
Thank you much, James. Ian, your first
question. Can you please explain First
Peter 3:19?
I've tried to understand it by reading
the surrounding verses and even into
chapter 4, but I'm still confused about
the meaning. And this is from Canada
also. And Heather,
>> all right, Heather, thank you so much.
And I hope you have your Bible with you
because we're going to need to uh follow
along and I hope you follow along with
me. Now, 1 Peter 3:19, it's one of those
verses that has sparked a lot of debate.
Um, you know, it says that Jesus went
and preached unto the spirits in prison.
But what exactly does that mean? There
are many schools of thought and some of
which are that Christ between his death
and resurrection went to hell to preach
to disembodied spirits to actually give
them a second chance. Uh there's also
this idea that Jesus went to a place
called purgatory. Um which stems
actually from the uh the Roman Catholic
Church, but that was actually met with
harsh criticism when that church started
using this in order to pay indulgences
and such. And then there's also another
thought of a pre-existent eternal Jesus.
Now, I'm going to we're going to break
this down and I want you to open up your
Bibles and if you can uh we're going to
start in verse 18. So, it's going to be
1 Peter 3 and verse 18 where it says,
"For Christ also suffered once for sins,
the just for the unjust, that he might
bring us to God, being put to death in
the flesh, but made alive, and this is
very important, by the spirit. By whom,
this is verse 19, by whom also he went
and preached." Now, if you look at the
end of verse 18, the Bible uses the word
spirit and it's actually capitalized.
Now this is indicating that this spirit
is in fact the holy spirit. So the same
spirit that as the text said says made
him alive is the same spirit in which
Christ is able to go and preach. So to
whom did Jesus preach to? Now it says to
the spirits in prison. Now this is where
many jump to actually a false conclusion
making the word prison to mean hell. But
this does not actually fall in line with
biblical teaching. The Bible never
actually uses the word prison as a
synonym for hell. What the actual words
that you'll find for death or for hell
are shol, Hades, Gehenna, and Tartarus.
But each one has a different sort of
nuance when referring to to hell or
death. So now in 1 Peter 3:19, when it
speaks of the spirits in prison, it's
actually speaking to or of people in a
world that are held captive by sin, not
souls in hell being preached to to give
a second chance. Because we're also told
in Hebrews chapter 9 and verse 27 where
it says uh it says and as it is
appointed to men to die once but after
this the judgment. So there are no
second chances. So what does this word
prison mean? So in scripture prison
actually uh typically means a literal
jail which you'll find throughout the
New Testament. In fact, if you look that
up, the majority of them are referring
to a literal jail. But it is also
throughout the Bible used symbolically
for people who are bound in sin or
darkness or in bondage to sin. You can
find this in Isaiah 42:7 which says to
open the blind eyes to bring out the
prisoners from the prison and them that
sit in darkness out of the prison house.
In Isaiah 6:11, it says, "The spirit of
the Lord of God is upon me, because the
Lord hath anointed me to preach good
tidings unto the meek. He has sent me to
bind up the brokenhearted, to proclaim
liberty to the captives, and the opening
of the prison to them that are bound."
And Jesus actually quotes himself Isaiah
6:1 and Luke 4:18. Now, these are Old
Testament references, so I want to give
you a New Testament reference as well,
so you have a balance. uh in Romans
chapter 7 and verse 23 says, "But I see
another law in my members, waring
against the law of my mind and bringing
me into captivity the to the law of sin
which is in my members." So now that
we've established all of that, who were
these spirits in prison? This is now um
we see what this who the spirits of
prison are in verse 20 of chapter 3 in 1
Peter which says which sometime were
disobedient when once the longsuffering
of God waited in the days of Noah while
the ark was preparing where in a few
that is eight souls were saved by water.
So Jesus preached by the Holy Spirit to
those who were disobedient in the days
of Noah. So, kind to recap everything
here. Uh, to summarize, 1 Peter 3:19
does not teach that Jesus went to hell.
To give people a second chance, the
Bible never uses the word prison to mean
hell. Instead, the spirits in prison
refers to the anti-dolivian world that
Jesus preached to by the Holy Spirit.
And the same that he preaches to them is
the same that he preaches to us today,
calling us out of that same prison and
into a freedom of salvation.
>> Wow.
>> Okay. It's a lot to say in a short time.
>> It is.
>> You did good.
>> Well, praise God.
>> Shelley,
>> your first question. What does the Bible
mean when it says, "If someone does not
work, neither shall he eat. Should I
help someone who is actively seeking
work?" And where is this verse found?
And this is from Vicki in Florida.
>> Vicki, the verse to which you refer is 2
Thessalonians 3:10. Paul says, "If
anyone will not work, neither shall he
eat." The text is not about refusing to
help the needy. It's about encouraging
personal responsibility. Paul's not
condemning those who can't find work.
He's addressing those who refuse to
work. And in their idleness they were
depending upon others expecting them to
support them. There this is a strong
biblical principle. If someone is able
to work but chooses not to, they should
not expect others to support them in
their idleness. The Bible also tells us
though that we should help those in
genuine need. In Proverbs 19:17,
Proverbs says, "He who has pity on the
poor lends to the Lord and he God will
pay back what that person has given." So
what I love, this is a great example of
Paul's writings. People get confused
sometimes with Galatians 6:2 and 6:5.
Let me read them very quickly. Galatians
6:2, Paul says, "Bear one another's
burdens and so fulfill the law of
Christ." Galatians 6:5, he says, "For
each one shall bear his own load." Is
Paul speaking out of both sides of his
mouth? No. When he says, "Bear one
another's burdens." In verse five, the
word is barose. It's a boulder. It is
something that is extra heavy load too
heavy for one individual to carry. In
verse five when he says each one shall
bear his own load. This word is portion
P h o r t i o n. It's a stone and it
refers to life's routine obligations. We
each have to carry our own
responsibilities. But when they become
overwhelming, we're supposed to be
helping one another. So if someone is
actively seeking work, this demonstrates
their willingness to contribute and it
is Christlike to offer encouragement and
practical help and temporary assistance.
Now we always want to help somebody in a
way that empowers them, not enables
them. So you don't want them to begin to
depend upon you. But you can provide
meals, help them with their resume, give
them transportation, help them network
for job opportunities.
But it is right and it is biblical to
help those who are trying to find work
to provide for themselves. You know, God
calls us to always balance compassion
and responsibility
and we help the willing
while we discourage idleness.
>> Amen. Very good. Shelley James, your
second question. Who are the four
carpenters in Zechariah 120? And this is
from Audra in Georgia.
Well, Audrey, that's uh the context of
this verse really will help us to
greatly understand who the four
carpenters represent. It's that's a
challenging question. Like Ian said
earlier, sometimes we get questions, and
I think Shelley mentioned this, that
really challenge us. And Shel, I really
love the answer you just gave. That was
a great great insight, very practical
for us in church when we're trying to
help people. So, Zechariah 1:18-21,
here's what it says. Now, I lifted up my
eyes, and I saw, and behold, four horns,
and I said unto the angel that talked
with me, what be these? And he answered
me, "These are the horns which have
scattered Judah, Israel, and Jerusalem."
And the Lord showed me four carpenters.
Then I said I, "What come came these to
do?" And he spake, saying, "These are
the horns which have scattered Judah, so
that no man did lift up his head, but
these, the four carpenters have come to
fray them to cast out the horns of the
Gentiles, which lifted up their horn
over the land of Judah to scatter it."
So the context of this is that these
four carpenters are going to unite or
gather what was scattered. Now we go to
the gospel. We go to the Bible. We go to
the New Testament because this is a
prophecy that was fulfilled in Jesus
Christ. You see Jesus Christ is the
carpenter. We're told that in Matthew
chapter 6 and verse three. And Jesus
came to gather God's scattered flock.
Notice these verses. Matthew 9:36.
But when he saw the multitudes, he was
moved with compassion on them because
they fainted and were scattered abroad
as sheep having no shepherd. Or Matthew
12:30,
he that is not with me is against me. He
that gatherth not with me scatterth
abroad. Or uh John 11:52
and not for that nation only, but also
that he should gather together in one
the children of God which were scattered
abroad. Speaking about all people in
this sense. So Jesus is represented by
the four gospels of the New Testament.
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John. They are
the four gospels of Jesus Christ. So I
would say that these are the four
carpenters. The gospels of Jesus the
carpenter are to unite those who've been
scattered abroad by the four horns.
Babylon, Meo, Persia, Greece, and Rome.
And by the way, Rome is still at work to
scatter in the composite beast of
Revelation 13 to scatter God's people
into confusion. But the carpenters, the
four gospels share the everlasting
gospel summarized in Revelation chapter
14. They go to every nation, kindred,
tongue, and people. They call people out
of the scattering, out of Babylon, out
of the confusion through the four
gospels. The carpenter draws all people
unto one body, one faith, one Lord, one
shepherd. And of course, we see that in
Ephesians. And we also see that in John,
where Jesus is the true shepherd, then
there'll be those who will hear his
voice and follow him. Isaiah 11 talks
about this and then Revelation chapter
18. That's all the time we have time
for, but I hope this helps Audrey to
answer the question.
>> Good answer. Good answer.
And number two, in times of trouble,
what does it really mean to focus on
God? Should I still pray about my
problems or only thank him? And this is
from Annabelle in United Kingdom.
>> You know, I really appreciate this
question, Annabelle. there's there's an
authenticity behind it and uh what I
want to say is that oftent times when we
fall into these periods of times of
trouble or trials in our life uh we as
humans you know we can end up being
hyperfocused on the problem rather than
the problem solver and it can detract
and deter from you know from what's
going on in our lives and there's a
spiritual principle that's found in se 2
Corinthians chapter 3 and 18 which says
by beholding we become changed now if
our main focus is on the trial and the
difficulties that we're experiencing,
then we're actually giving that more
strength. Uh whether it be finances or
marriage or even jobs or even ministry.
Uh whatever it might be, everything that
we experience and the trials we go
through, we want it. We want to make
sure that's not pulling away from our
focus on God. Now, he should always be
our focus, right? In Hebrews uh 12:2, it
says he's the author and finisher of our
faith. Now when I think of your
question, I also think of Matthew
chapter 14 in verses 28 and 31. Now in
this section here, Peter is there's this
storm taking place and Peter is walking
on water and the only time that he is
able to accomplish this despite the
storm around him is when his eyes are
fixed on Christ. But the moment that he
takes his eyes and fixes his attention
away from Jesus is the moment that he
begins to sink. And so the the question
also that you asked is should I not pray
about my problems and just thank God
only? Well, what does Jesus tell us to
do? Matthew 11 28 he says come to me all
you who are who are who labor and are
heavy laden and I will give you rest. So
in other words come to him with your
problems come to him with your
struggles. Come to him with your heavy
hearts because that's exactly what he
wants you to do. Jesus wants us to
depend on him completely and entirely. 1
Peter 5:7 says, "Casting all your care
upon him, for he cares for you." And
then also as we navigate these difficult
moments in our life, whatever it might
be experiencing, we're told in Psalm 50
and:e1 15 says, "Call upon me in the day
of trouble. I will deliver you and you
shall glorify me." And also in Psalm 34
and verses 17 and 18, the righteous cry
out and the Lord hears and delivers them
out of all their troubles. The Lord is
near to those who have a broken heart
and save such as have a contrite spirit.
And then one of my favorite verses, and
many people are familiar with this,
Philippians 4:es 6 and 7, be anxious for
nothing, but in everything prayer and
supplication with thanksgiving, let your
requests be made known to God. And the
peace of God which surpasses all
understanding will guard your hearts and
minds through Christ Jesus. So to answer
your question, the Bible actually
teaches both. We are to pray about our
problems because God cares and we are to
thank him because we trust in his power.
So focusing on God means keeping our
eyes on him rather than being consumed
by the trial. But as problems grow and
we stare or problems grow when we stare
at them, but peace grows as we behold
Jesus. Amen. Wow. Amen.
>> Shelly
number two. The Bible says our names
were written in the book before we were
formed. Does that mean that everyone
starts in the book of life until they
choose to reject Christ? This is from
Susie in Colorado.
>> Susie, you're referring to Psalm 139:16.
I'll read it from the amplified. Your
eyes saw my unformed substance and in
your book all the days of my life were
written before they ever took shape when
as yet there was none of them. The Bible
speaks of several books and everybody's
name is in the books. Um the records are
not kept for God's memory because he's
omnisient. they are kept. You know,
Isaiah 46:10, God says that he declares
the end from the beginning. So, he knows
how it's going to turn out. But the
purpose of these books is for the
universe to see God's mercy and
righteous judgment. how he showed mercy
to repentant sinners. How he confirms
justice in rejecting the rebellious and
upholds
the freedom of the human choice. I think
that free will is so important. They
provide these books will provide
transparency in judgment. We see that
judgment scene in Daniel 7:10 where it
says that the court was seated and the
books were opened. Well, let's look at
the books. There's the book of life. And
as I understand it from all the
scriptures I've read, everyone who
accepts Christ the Messiah, whether they
were from the Old Testament or saints or
the New Testament, the Old Testament, if
they accepted the Messiah and his
covenant, their name was written in the
book of life. The New Testament the
same. Revelation 21:20 said and says,
"There shall by no means enter it,
Jerusalem, the new Jerusalem, anything
that defiles or causes an abomination or
a lie, but only those who are written in
the Lamb's book of life." Daniel 12:1
and2 says at the time of the end it says
your people shall be delivered and
everyone who is found written in the
book and I believe this is the book of
life because it say they're going to be
delivered many of those who sleep in the
dust shall awake some to everlasting
life that's the first resurrection
some to shame and everlasting contempt
the second resurrection
it's important to Note that the name,
your name, you can accept Christ be
written in the lamb's book of life. And
it can be blotted out. In Exodus 32:33,
the Lord said to Moses, "Whoever has
sinned against me, I will blot him out
of my book." And Jesus said in
Revelation 3:5, "He who overcomes shall
be clothed in white garments." That's
his robes of righteousness. And I will
not blot blot out his name from the book
of life, but I will confess his name
before my father and his angels. Final
judgment is going to decide who remains
in that book of life. The names that
remain in the book of life are our name
will remain in the book of life only if
we continue in Christ. It's not once
saved always saved. you, God never takes
away your free will. And I've seen
people who were so committed even in
ministry, committed to the Lord, who
suddenly just and they went nuts and
they turned around and they rejected
Christ and went on a tantrum and their
name would be blotted out. Now, I really
quickly there's a book of remembrance.
This records the loyal uh loyalty,
words, and deeds. Malachi 3:16 tells you
about that. It shows that God values
every act. He even records our traumas
in that book of remembrance. Psalm 56:8,
David said, "You're you number my
wanderings. Put my tears in your bottle.
Are they not in your books?"
And then in the there's a book of works.
They contain the record of every thought
and deed. Matthew 12:37, Jesus says, "By
your words, you're you're justified, or
by your words, you will be condemned."
And Revelation 202 is telling us about
the great white throne judgment. This is
the second resurrection. Everyone's
coming up from the second resurrection.
They're standing before God. And the
books, all of them, were open. And
another book was open, which is the book
of life. and the dead were judged
according to their works by the things
that were written in the books. So these
books serve as evidence and in the
investigative judgment be before the
first resurrection and before Christ
that's before Christ returns for his
faithful followers and it's evidence of
God's fairness in his decisions.
>> Wow. Thank you Shelley. That was really
good. There's three ways of getting in
contact with us. I just want to uh
remind the of how to do that. If you
want to text us, it's 6182283975.
If you'd like to email it, bible
qa3abn.tv
and of course with Instagram 3ABN
official.
We love getting your questions in. James
number three.
Why did the Lord speak to Satan in Job 1
7 and8? And this is from Zelia in South
Africa.
>> Thank you, Zelia from South Africa. You
know, the Lord spoke to Satan because
well, he's the only one who can speak to
Satan with true rebuking authority. You
know, we see this truth illustrated in
Jude 9, for example. It says there, "Yet
Michael the archangel contending with
the devil. He disputed about the body of
Moses. durst not bring against him a
railing accus accusation but said the
Lord rebuke thee. So the Lord spoke to
Satan not only because the Lord is the
only one who can hold Satan or the devil
in check but also because we need him to
speak in our behalf. And this is
illustrated in Zechariah 3:1 and2. He
showed me Joshua the high priest
standing before the angel of the Lord
and Satan standing at his right hand to
resist him. And the Lord said unto
Satan, "The Lord rebuked thee, oh Satan.
Even the Lord that hath chosen
Jerusalem, rebuke thee. Is not this a
brand plucked out of the fire?" Again,
Zechariah 3:1 and2. So the Lord spoke to
Satan because Satan claimed this earth
is his, and it's not. The earth is the
Lord's and the fullness thereof, the
world and they that dwelt therein. So,
we see that when the devil comes walsing
into God's gathering of the sons of God
and claiming to be representing this
planet, God is going to say something
about that. And I'm so thankful because
that means that when the devil comes
walking into our lives and creating
havoc, God is going to say something
about that, too. Praise God. You know,
my mother once told me when I was a lad,
she said, "Jamie," you know, she named
me James, but she called me Jamie. Moms
can do that. She said, "Jamie, the only
thing necessary for evil to prosper is
for good men to do nothing. So God is
not going to do nothing when the devil
struts in, claiming planet earth and the
human family as his." In other words,
the Lord spoke to the devil to put him
in his place to remove any chance of his
claiming us and finally to let him
reveal what it would be like if he was
actually the ruler of planet Earth.
That's what we have in the story of Job.
When you look at the story of Job, you
have Job experiencing the loss of his
children, of his wealth, of his health,
of his friends, and of his reputation.
And if you want to lose everything in
this life that means anything, keep
shutting God out of your life and keep
letting the devil come in. That's the
story of Job. But God restores
everything to Job because Job refused to
give up his hold on God. He refused to
stop believing in God and trusting God.
He struggled as we all do. But he
maintained his idelity to the God of
heaven. And you and I can do the same
thing.
>> Amen. Good.
Ian, this is a long question.
I've been wondering how to study the
Bible more deeply. I do read it
frequently, but I've heard that
memorization is important. However, I
find it difficult to remember verses
perfectly for a long time. Do we need to
memorize the Bible? If so, what are some
easy methods to do so effectively? And
this is from Jenny.
>> All right, Jenny. Amen. That you're
asking the question, uh, you know, how
to study the Bible more deeply. And
honestly, I think we all ask that
question throughout, you know, our walk
with God is, I want to know how to study
more deeply. Well, I'm going to give you
just a couple of things or tools that
you could do. Um, there's something
called the topical study. So, what you
could do is you can pick a, you know,
choose a theme like redemption or prayer
or even the Holy Spirit and you can use
different softwares that are out there.
There's tons of different softwares,
some that are free, some that are paid
and you can gather all the verses that
are dealing with that topic or that word
and do that topical study. You can also
do a book or a chapter study where and
what you would do is you just choose a
chapter or choose a book within the
Bible and you would just read it. Read
it repeatedly. Read it frequently over
and over and over again. and you just
pull out the different themes and maybe
um you know the background of the
author, the audience in which it was
written, the setting in which the
writing was done and you could do it
that way. Some other things you could do
is you could do a prophecy or a typology
study uh such as something on the
sanctuary or the feast days or even
Daniel and Revelation. We have a lot of
programs here on 3ABN that dive a lot
into prophecy and a typology study such
as salvation and symbols and signs which
pastor James Raferty heads out. Uh we
also do a program by Dr. David Shinn
called sanctuary salvation and our
savior. And then there's one other
method that pastor James Rafferty
mentioned earlier and that is which I
you know may be a little bit biased and
recommend which is that you would come
to the 3abian school of disciplehip
because we have a class specifically
dedicated to this on how to study the
Bible more deeply. In fact we even have
a class on how to study Bible prophecy.
So, uh, you also asked though, do we
need to memorize our Bible? And what are
some easy methods? So, I hope you have a
pen and paper because I'm not going to
read the verses. I'm just going to note
them. But absolutely, do we need to
memorize scripture in God's word? You
can take uh memorizing scripture
actually helps us fight sin. You can
find that in Psalm 119 and verse 11.
Memorizing scripture gives us wisdom.
You can find that in 2 Timothy 3:15. uh
memorizing scripture gives us direction
and is our guide. So when we when we
hold that into our heart and we can pull
that out when we're looking for
direction and you can find that in Psalm
119:105.
And memorizing scripture actually gives
you perfect peace when you hold God's
word into your heart and your mind is
fixed on him. You can find that on
Isaiah 26:3. But not only is it
beneficial to you, but it is also
beneficial to others as well, which you
can note in Colossians 3:16. This one
I'm am going to read where it says, "Let
the word of Christ dwell in you richly
in all wisdom, teaching and admonishing
one another." So, what are some easy
methods to memorize scripture? Well, I'm
going to give you three. There's
repetition, repetition, and repetition.
It is the only way that you can memorize
scripture is just doing it over and over
and over again. But there are some
things that I might help you or that you
do better than others and vice versa.
So, you could do it visually. you just
read it over and over and over again.
You can do it auditory. You're just
speaking it out loud over and repeating.
Or you could do uh a kinesthetic where
you write it. And for me, I actually
have to speak it and write it. And that
helps me memorize it. So, immerse
yourself in God's word and just keep
repeating it. Memorize the scripture.
And also come to the 3BN school
disciplehip where you will learn how to
study the Bible more deeply.
>> There you go. Amen.
>> Great.
>> Amen. That's very good, Shellyley. Third
question. This is a long one. Was the
ark of the covenant with the tablets
inside present in the rebuilt temple
after the 70-year capti captivity?
If not, how were burnt offerings
conducted without it, especially during
Jesus' time on earth? Was the ark of the
covenant present in the second temple
temple? And if not, how were burnt
offerings conducted without it? And this
is Tom from Texas.
>> Tom from Texas. We like Texas. I like
this question.
>> The ark disappeared from the record of
the Bible. The last clear mention of the
ark in the Old Testament was during King
Josiah's reign. And you find that in 2
Corinthians, excuse me, 2 Chronicles 35
and verse three. After Babylon destroyed
Solomon's temple in 586 BC, the ark is
never listed among the items that the
sacred vessels that were returned from
exile. You find those list ex in Ezra
1:es 7-11. Jewish tradition holds that
the ark was hidden either by uh Jeremiah
or some other faithful priest. And you
can find a reference to that even though
this book is not a a part of the
Protestant cannon. You can find that
record in second Mcabes 2 verses 4-8.
The second temple,
the most holy place of the second temple
was empty. Historical source sources
like Josephus
in his book, War of the Jews, this is
book five, chapter 5, confirm that the
most holy place in Herod's temple was an
empty chamber. No ark, no mercy seat.
The high priests still entered on the
day of atonement. We find that in
Leviticus 30 or 16 about the day of
atonement. And he still did. But he
sprinkled the blood on the foundation
stone where the ark had once stood. I
love the thought came to me just a while
ago. I wrote this in real quickly. 1
Corinthians 3:11 says, "No other
foundation can anyone lay other than
that which is has been laid, which is
Jesus Christ."
See, well, let me let me make my final
point, then I'll get to that summation.
The burnt offerings did not require the
ark. The daily burnt offerings that we
see prescribed in Exodus 29:38-42
were made in the outer court at the
altar of burnt offering, not on the ark.
The ark's absence didn't stop the
sacrifice because the altar which
represented Christ's atoning sacrifice
was still in place. What was missing
were the were the visible symptoms
visible symbols of God's presence and
his covenant. That's what was missing in
the most holy place. And you know that's
an interesting thought.
I was thinking about this. You can have
a form of religious practice that's
absent of God's presence. That's kind of
scary, isn't it? But the ark's absence
foreshadowed
the shift from the earthly symbols to
Christ himself as our high priest in
heaven. Find that Hebrews 8:1 and2. When
Jesus was on the earth, the temple
ceremonies continued, but the true mercy
seat was already in the heavenly
sanctuary.
And like I say, there's a lot of work
that goes into this, you know. Thank
you, Shellyley. James, question number
four. Can you please explain First Kings
17 to 30 verses 17 to 23? Did God use a
fallen angel in this passage? Is God
condoning a sin he would never commit,
something abominable to him? I'm
struggling to understand his character
in this story. And this is from Brittany
in Virginia.
>> Thank you, Britney. Uh let's just read
the verses. First Kings chapter
22:17-23.
And he said, "I saw all Israel scattered
upon the hills as sheep that have not a
shepherd." And the Lord said, "These
have no master. Let them return every
man to his house in peace." And the king
of Israel said unto Jehoshaphat, "Did I
not tell you that he would prophesy no
good concerning me but evil?" And he
said, "Hear thou therefore the word of
the Lord. I saw the Lord sitting on his
throne, and all the host of heaven
standing by him on his right hand and on
his left." And the Lord said, "Who shall
persuade Ahab that he may go up and fall
at Ramothth Gilead." And one said on
this manner, and the other said on that
manner, and they came forth a spirit,
and stood before the Lord, and said, I
will persuade him. And the Lord said
unto him, Wherewith? And he said, I will
go forth and I will be a lying spirit in
the mouth of all his prophets. And he
said, Thou shalt persuade him and
prevail also. Go forth and do so. Now
therefore, behold, the Lord has put a
lying spirit in the mouth of all these
prophet thy prophets and the Lord has
spoken evil concerning thee. So this is
a difficult story and I wanted to read
it in a larger context because it helps
us to understand what's going on behind
the scenes. It appears that a lying
spirit is what persuades Ahab and that
spirit comes from God. However, when we
understand the story, we recognize that
the true prophet of God is explaining
the source of the false prophets who are
persuading Ahab and Jehoshaphat to do
something that is not God's will.
So, our understanding begins really in
verse 5. And Jehoshaphat said unto the
king of Israel, inquire, I pray thee at
the word of the Lord today. Then the
king of Israel gathered the prophets
together about 400 men and said unto
them, shall I go against Ramothgilead to
battle or shall I forebear? And they
said, "Go up, for the Lord shall deliver
it into the hand of the king." Now
that's verses 5 and six of the same
chapter, First Kings 22. So here we see
lying prophets claiming to be inspired
of God and thus we have a reference to
God's throne room where these lying
prophets claim connection to. So when we
see the true prophet explaining the
situation Micaiah we understand that uh
Micaiah we understand that he is
explaining what has taken place in the
context of these lying prophets. Now
Jehoshaphat doesn't trust Ahab's
prophets for good reason. And so he asks
for a prophet of the Lord besides these.
And Ahab points to Micaiah and the son
of Ilma and but he admits that this
prophet hates him because basically this
is the only prophet that tells the truth
about or to Ahab. So when um Ma shows up
he prophesies as the false prophets have
done. He encourages them to go and fight
the Syrians and then Ahab adjures him to
speak the truth and he tells them then
that Israel will be scattered abroad if
they fight against Syria. So he tells
him the truth and then Ahab responds and
basically says you see he always
prophesies evil concerning me and at
this point the true prophet shares the
verses in question. And so this is how
we understand them. They these are what
God sees regarding human hearts. And
therefore God allows those human hearts
who refuse to listen to him to or to his
true messages to do what they have
purposed to do in their hearts. So God
is then seen as doing what he's allowed
in this story. And this happens in many
other places like the story of Job. You
know, because God is sovereign and he
sees all and he understands all, he's
seen as the one that is doing certain
things because he allows certain things.
And yet ultimately when God gives over
us over to lying spirits, it's only he's
only honoring our freedom. Michel talked
about earlier. It's amazing that God
honors this freedom of choice that he's
given to human beings to make our own
decisions. So, this story makes that
crystal clear because we see both Ahab
and Jehoshaphat disregarding the words
of the true prophet even though they
know him to be speaking from the truth
from God and listening to the words of
the false prophets, 400 of them. Which
means basically that God is summarizing,
hey, who's going to go and lie? Oh, I'll
go. a false spirit is going to go from
the throne of God only because God is
sovereign and God allows that which we
choose. Uh he allows us a certain time
where he holds that back. But then as we
persist in our rebelling against him, he
finally lets us go. He finally honors
our free choice. And of course we see
that in Romans chapter 1. There's a lot
more to this question. I hope that helps
a little bit.
>> Amen. You did good. Ian, another long
one. I'm planning a time of prayer and
fasting and usually end my fast at 12
pm. Though I'd like to extend it to 3
pm. I recently heard that fasting until
noon isn't really considered fasting,
just prayer. What are your thoughts?
This is a viewer from California.
>> All right. Well, thank you uh for that
question. Now, first off, what I want to
say is fasting is simply between you and
God. Amen. So if you have somebody
telling you well to this time is not a
fast but this time is I'm sorry but this
is between you and God. There is no
minimum of time that you need to fast.
Now there are some people that happen to
be expert fasters and some who may
struggle a bit. I know I struggle a
little bit when it comes to fasting. My
wife can attest to that. Um but if you
want to fast you can also look into the
Bible. There are many different types of
fast and even days. Uh Moses fasted for
40 days where he neither ate nor drank.
And you can find that in Exodus 34:28.
Esther and the Jews fasted for three
days. You can find that in Esther 4 uh
verse 16. Daniel actually did a partial
fast for 3 weeks. Uh you can find that
in Daniel 10 and verse uh in verse
three. Now, if we make the fasting about
a clock though, we miss the complete
purpose of what fasting and the true
nature really is all about. And what God
desires is for hearts to be seeking him,
not just empty stomachs. So Jesus
actually warned us about making fasting
a performance. You can find this in
Matthew 6 16 and 18. And I'm going to go
ahead and read it, which says,
"Moreover, when you fast, do not be like
the hypocrites with a sad countenance.
For they disfigure their faces that they
may appear to be men to be fasting.
Assuredly, I say to you, they have their
reward. But you, when you fast, anoint
your head and wash your face, that you
do not appear to be men to be fasting,
but to your father who is in a secret
place or sees." Yeah. your father who is
in the secret place and your father who
sees in secret will reward you openly.
Now, there are some basic principles to
fasting. But before we go ahead, I'm
kind of going to put everybody here on
the spot a little bit because I didn't
tell you this ahead of time, but when
you think of the word fasting and and
abstaining from something, what is the
first thing that comes to your mind?
>> Food.
>> Food. Exactly. Food. But fasting isn't
always about food. except especially in
this uh in this world of technology. Uh
it can be a fasting from social media.
It could be a fast from TV or from
movies. It could be a fast from
something that maybe you're just
struggling with and you want to put it
away for a while so that you can focus
on God rather than that thing holding
your attention, but rather God holding
your attention.
>> Phone fast.
>> A phone fast. Yeah, I know. I'm for me,
I'm glued to mine because I'm always
answering emails and texting and things
like that. And sometimes even when we're
studying we have to put our phone down,
put it on silent, put it away so we can
have that time with God. But also
fasting is also giving ourselves to
others. In Isaiah 58 verse 6 and 7 it
says, "Is this not the fast that I have
chosen to loose the bonds of the wicked
or to loose the bonds of wickedness to
undo the heavy burdens to let the
oppressed go free and to break and that
you break every yoke? Is it not to share
your bread with the hungry and that you
bring to your house the poor who are
cast out when you see the naked that you
cover him and not hide yourself from
your own flesh. So in closing, fasting
is isn't about how many hours you go
without food or it's really about
drawing us closer to you. So it is an
agreement between you and God and that's
all that really matters.
>> Amen.
>> That was very good Ian. Very good.
>> Shelley number four. I pay tithe and
offerings and so does my daughter. We
live together. I know I should tithe on
my earnings and increase. If she gives
me money for bills or groceries, should
I pay tithe on what she gives me or only
what I have left after expenses and this
is from a viewer in Louisiana.
>> I appreciate this question so much. I
wished I knew your name because it's a
precious heart. The Bible teaches that a
tithe is a tenth of our increase. And so
that's our personal income that's coming
in. If, for example, if you're a salary
employee and let's say you make $2,000 a
month, you're tithing on your 2,000. If
you're in a business owner and uh your
business makes say 10,000 but the cost
of goods was 5,000, you're only
uh tithing on your increase. In your
case, first I wanted to tell you the
tithe God says is holy and belongs to
him. We don't pay tithe, we return it.
God has given it to us and it's a trust
factor that we return it to him. So,
here's the point. If your daughter is
giving you, say you've got a $392
electric bill and she gives you $200
toward that bill, this is a
reimbursement. That's not your increase
because it's a shared cost. She lives
with you. If she gives you a $100 for
groceries, that also's not an increase,
assuming that it's her contribution
toward your shared food, you you're
simply passing it on to the electric
company and the grocery store. So,
you're not required to pay that money.
The tithe is 10% of what God blesses you
with. Now, if your daughter say gave you
$200 as a gift at Christmas time and it
had nothing to do with reimbursing
expense, that's when you would tithe on
it. You're tithing on your increase,
your income, your gifts, and what God
has given to you.
>> Thank you, Shelley. Appreciate all the
work that you put in. That was a great
answer. you know, just want to take a
few minutes here and uh just going to
have an address row so that you can kind
of see how to submit your questions to
us. We love your questions. God bless
you.
>> If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
[Music]
Be sure to include your name and where
you live. And then watch Bible Q&A for
answers from God's word.
Welcome back. Do we have any additional
comments on what we've been talking
about?
>> I'd just like to say that you want your
name written in the lamb's book of life.
And all that means is that you open your
heart. Give God a chance. Let don't
reject his love. accept his love and his
power of the Holy Spirit to help you go
forward in covenant obedience.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah. I just wanted to touch again on
the very first question that I had which
was about 1 Peter 3:19 because there's
so much information about this and I
think what's really paramount for anyone
to understand uh 1 Peter 3:19 is
understanding that Jesus is eternal and
pre-existent. Amen. And I want to give
you just a la, you know, I'm not going
to read them, but I just want to throw
these out there for your reference. John
1 1-3 and verse14, John 17:5, Colossians
1:14-16,
Hebrews 13:8, and Revelation 22:13
because I think that is really paramount
in order to understand 1 Peter 3:19.
>> Amen. James, would you like to share
with us?
>> Yeah. Job chapter 1 or actually chapter
two. And I just want look at this uh
verse here. Verse three. And the Lord
said unto Satan, "Hast thou considered
my servant Job, that there is none like
him in the earth, a perfect and an
upright man, one that fears God and
turns away from evil. And still he holds
fast his integrity, although thou moved
me against him to destroy him without
cause." Obviously, God was not the one
that was moved against Job. And God was
not the one that took out his kids and
took out his wealth and took out his
health. That was Satan. But you see how
God speaks as though he's the one
because he's sovereign and he allowed
Satan to step into that situation. This
story helps us to understand the
question that we looked at in First
Kings where we see it seems God sending
a lying spirit while God is allowing the
false prophets to believe a lying spirit
rather than actually sending that
spirit.
>> Amen. Well, I just want to thank all
three of you. Amen.
>> I mean, I know how much work that you
put into this and that certainly we want
to uh thank you for watching, for tuning
in with us. Just know that at 3ABN that
we love each and every one of you, and I
know that God has a plan for each one of
us. So, just keep your eyes focused on
him. God bless you.
>> Amen.
[Music]
Really?